[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue avant direct votre
émission pour aller plus loin ce soir
sur un duel de second tour qui ressemble
à un choc frontal tout oppose
emmanuel macron et marine le pen quelle
sera alors la tonalité de cette nouvelle
campagne c'est une france est divisée au
lendemain du premier tour
comment rassembler rien et à qui on va
en parler avec de nombreux invités en
notre compagnie
et maintenant quelle ligne quels projets
et quel leader à droite le parti se
réveille groggy françois fillon se met
en retrait à l'issue de leur bureau
politique et républicains appellent à
voter contre marine le pen sur ce sujet
et cette situation le match des idées
opposera tout à l'heure anne levade
juriste professeur de droit à
l'académicien jean marie rouart
enfin l'entretien avec un peu plus de
recul on va analyser les conséquences du
vote hier le paysage politique avec le
philosophe michel onfray qu'est-ce qui
peut vraiment changer avec cette
présidentielle
le regard critique du philosophe tout à
l'heure voilà donc pour le programme
merci de nous suivre vos réactions et
question avec le hashtag aux apl et
avant notre premier débat voici le
résumé de l'actualité du jour avec
mounir souci
[Musique]
je vais redevenir un militant de coeur
parmi les autres je vais devoir penser
madiot autrement pensez aussi les plaies
de ma famille c'est par ces mots que
françois fillon a conclu sa prise de
parole devant le bureau politique des
républicains
il estime ne plus être légitime pour
mener la bataille des législatives
marine le pen
et dans de la république est le
président de tous les français et qu'à
ce titre il doit donc rassembler tous
les français alors c'est une conviction
profonde mais il faut maintenant passer
des paroles aux actes et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il m'est apparu
indispensable de me mettre en congé de
la présidence du front national
ce soir je ne suis donc plus la
présidente du front national je suis la
candidate à la présidentielle
en france
les deux finalistes de la présidentielle
seront côte à côte demain à la
préfecture de police de paris françois
hollande les a conviés à l'hommage rendu
aux policiers tués en service sur les
champs elysées par un homme se
revendiquant de dèche
marine le pen a confirmé sa présence sur
twitter et l'entourage des manuels
macron assure qu' a priori il sera
présent emmanuel ma cour
pour son premier déplacement depuis sa
qualification au second tour emmanuel
macron est venu déposer une gerbe en
souvenir des victimes du génocide
arménien le candidat explique qu'il est
favorable à une journée de commémoration
inscrite dans le calendrier
manifestation
à l'appel de sos racisme et de plusieurs
syndicats étudiants des centaines de
personnes se sont rassemblées place de
la république à paris pour dire non au
front national et pousser à une
mobilisation massive pour le second tour
il y a finalement chez beaucoup de gens
une forme d'évidence que marine le pen
va être battu au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
je tiens à faire remarquer que le second
tour est un second tour assez inédit qui
est un second tour il y aura sans doute
beaucoup de volatilité et qu'il n'ya
aucune évidence a priori que cette
personne soit battu à droite
[Musique]
à un cheveu des 5% synonymes de
remboursement des frais de campagne
nicolas dupont aignan lance un appel aux
dons pour couvrir une partie des
dépenses de son parti debout la france à
cette semaine pour réunir 300 mille euro
et équilibrer ses comptes avant de les
déposer
les candidats en dessous des 5% sont
remboursés de leurs prêts par l'état à
hauteur de 800 mille 423 euros
polémique
le patron de lafarge holcim payent pour
les agissements de son groupe en syrie
eric olson démissionne après des mois de
polémiques autour de l'activité du
cimentier en syrie un rapport accuse le
groupe d'avoir maintenu son activité
dans le pays et coopérer avec l'état
islamique entre 2011 et 2014 quand la
guerre faisait rage
le directeur général quittera ses
fonctions le 15 juillet
[Musique]
une nouvelle campagne qui démarre avec
deux visions deux projets et deux
candidats que tout oppose macron le pen
en vendée battre bien sûr et puis le
candidat dans marche qui engrange les
soutiens à gauche avec françois hollande
et la droite qui appelle à voter contre
marine le pen
le tout sur fond d'une france divisée
coupé en deux voire plus le débat avec
nos invités ce soir christine clairmont
soir soit un journaliste essayiste
auteur du livre j'ai vu cinq présidents
faire naufrage aux éditions robert
laffont avec nous également erwan eau en
bon soir professeur de droit sciences po
chroniqueur à l'opinion et auteur du
livre la france des opportunités aux
éditions les belles lettres
véronique reis août nous accompagnent
bonsoir spécialiste des réseaux sociaux
et directrice générale de dentsu
consulting et l'historien jean garrigues
et avec nos bons soirs président du
comité d'histoire parlementaire et
politique et auteur notamment de
président au pluriel au coeur du pouvoir
alors mesdames messieurs c'est le jour
d'après la campagne de second tour a
donc démarré pour emmanuel macron et
marine le pen nouvelle campagne sur fond
d'une france divisée s deux visages d'un
même pays deux candidats pour un seul
pays les détails avec géraldine bavois
loin on en parle juste après je tape ce
premier tour il y à une france de l'est
et une france de l'ouest comme le révèle
la carte du vote par département pour
l'élection présidentielle à l'ouest
emmanuel macron arrive en tête sauf dans
trois départements la mayenne l'orne et
la sarthe où françois fillon parvient à
tirer son épingle du jeu électoral à
l'est
marine le pen arrive en tête dans une
majorité de départements la candidate fn
réalise de bons scores dans le nord la
vallée du rhône mais son score est aussi
très fort dans la région paca marseille
accepter ou jean luc mélenchon gagne son
pari
en arrivant en tête comme à toulouse les
villes face aux campagnes
c'est l'autre enseignement de ce premier
tour emmanuel macron est plus fort dans
les villes mais marine le pen gagne dans
plus de 18000 commune soit la moitié des
communes françaises
le candidat dans marche quand huit
millions et demi d'électeurs concentrés
dans des villes comme lyon villeurbanne
ou strasbourg après avoir voté françois
hollande en 2012
deux candidats que tout oppose christine
clerc deux projets et de france aussi
qui se font face oui mais voilà beaucoup
dire la france d'en haut et la france
d'en bas on voit la france de l'ess
désindustrialisé on voit la lorraine ce
sont des zones entières qui ont été
qui ont perdu leur industrie textile
sidérurgique et on a vu des gens de la
cgt j'en ai rencontré passée au fn je
crois qu'il faudrait quand même affiné
parce que d'abord il ya quand même des
privilégiés qui vote le pen
il ya aussi des gens du peuple qui vote
macron donc c'est pas je voyais là les
régions ouest une région comme comme la
manche par exemple et beaucoup de gens
qui votent fn alors ont ils ne sont pas
ils sont pas en premier évidemment les
premiers ont voté mac rompuy fillon mais
la fin est quand même très important et
là quand même énormément monté et là
c'est pourquoi ces ses taux s'il s'est
pas la désindustrialisation mais c'est
une forme de désertification et puis
c'est la peur de l'immigration
ses thèmes ses thèmes sont quand même
très très fort je crois qu'il faut une
fois qu'on a dit france d'en-haut france
d'en bas il faut quand même
véritablement affiné c'est un peu trop
simple oui j'en garde des sceaux dans le
détail avec un clivage fort quand même
sur l'europe la place de la france dans
l'europe dans le monde est forcément des
perdants et des gagnants de cette
mondialisation aujourd'hui je dirais
enfin le vrai débat n'est sûr là et sur
la place publique
au fond c'est très cohérent ce vote et
puis ce deuxième tour il est le fruit de
quarante ans d'échecs de nos
gouvernements successifs des dix années
où on a cru qu'on pourrait réenchanter
la politique après nicolas sarkozy et
ségolène royal et on arrive aujourd'hui
au choix majeurs est-ce qu'on va vers
une adaptation plus ou moins réussis par
une sorte de nouvel effort libéral vers
la mondialisation heureuse ou est ce que
on se replie sur sur le national sur
l'identitaire éventuellement sur
l'exclusion et le problème c'est que
évidemment ce cet enjeu là il recoupe
une vraie césure sociologique ou je
dirais socioculturel et qu'on a
effectivement avec toutes les nuances
que christine terre eu raison d'
apporter
on a malgré tout quand même le paysage
de 2
ceux qui s'opposent et cette opposition
on va la trouver
pendant cette campagne de second tour
mais elle va pas s'arrêter au lendemain
de l'élection présidentielle donc cette
élection présidentielle lourde de jeu
des rides de risque de danger potentiel
ça on va en parler mais cette césure ce
clivage est roi nanan les deux candidats
qu'on retrouve au second tour ils ont
presque tout fait pour l'installer pour
marine le pen elle a toujours voulu
installer ce clivage dit-elle entre
patriotes et puis mondialiste mais
également emmanuel macron aider le
défunt a c'est tout leur s'accompagne
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron s'est posé en
opposant premier contradicteurs de
marine le pen est elle également et est
tout même cela une partie de son
discours a consisté à l'expliquer qu'il
était le meilleur rempart face à marine
le pen d'ailleurs il ya un sondage à
paraître demain dans les échos je
regardais tout à l'heure qui montre que
45 % des électeurs qui ont voté pour
emmanuel macron ont voté par vote utile
plus que par conviction c'est celui pour
lequel c'est le plus fort c'est aussi le
candidat qui a de ce qu'une des
principaux celui qui a le plus faible
taux d'adhésion à son programme donc
c'est assez intéressant c'est révélateur
comme vous disiez d'une crise qui est
profonde dans la cité française dans les
clivages qu'on a montré on pourrait
aussi dire que si on cumule françois
fillon benoît hamon et emmanuel macron
on est à 50,01 % des voix que cinq donc
les 49.99 autres ont voté pour soi pour
marine le pen soit pour jean luc
mélenchon soit pour les autres candidats
qui s'affiche comme étant hors système
c'est le clivage il est très fort
évidemment ça ne disparaîtra pas avec
l'élection du président de la république
et en même temps ce qui peut être un peu
est ce que je trouve un peu inquiétant
c'est que les thèmes dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure les migrations
l'adulte réalisations sont pas du tout
les thèmes dont on a débattu pendant la
campagne présidentielle
il est peut-être temps présent
effectivement et planes est quand même
sur cette campagne
véronique résoudre grâce à vous on
associe souvent l'impact l'importance
l'influencent aujourd'hui des réseaux
sociaux qui est vraiment lié intimement
aux campagnes aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous également sur ces raisons on a vu
ce clivage se dessiner
et je vais pas dire c'est de france ça
serait caricatural sur les réseaux
sociaux mais quand même une sorte de
tension de saisir alors tension oui mais
déjà de même dans l'usagé des réseaux
sociaux c'est à dire que on voit bien
que l'électorat de marine le pen c'est
un électorat qui est plus présent sur
facebook et les lecteurs en caricaturant
parce que bien sûr ça n'est pas que là
et les électeurs de macron sont aussi
sur facebook mais plus facile voix sur
facebook et l'électorat de maquereau est
plus facilement sur twitter donc déjà il
ya ce petit clivages en soi et puis on a
aussi une réalité d'une organisation de
la fameuse fasse chaud ce fait puisque
c'est ainsi qu'on l'appelait car un peu
changé ils sont un peu moins on va dire
intrusif et surtout ils sont organisés
aujourd'hui en deux communautés un peu
différente il ya ceux qui soutiennent
plutôt le courant dit de gauche à
l'intérieur du front national et ceux
qui soutiennent plutôt le courant
historique et même
donc c'est pas si simple que ça donc en
tout cas en ligne on voit bien que les
choses ne sont pas si harmonieuse et si
simple que seul un mois aussi sur le
hashtag sans moi le 7 mai vous l'avez
évidemment vu fait florès ça voudrait
dire que certains électeurs nombreux
électeurs sont un peu perdus et décide
de ne pas aller voter
de quoi s'agit-il elle enseigne aussi
c'est acheter il s'est lancé de façon
spontanée donc comme tous les acheteurs
qui sont dans cette façon spontanée
c'est ce qui a fait qu'ils sont plus
repris on a regardé avec visible rennes
qui est une plateforme de veille des
réseaux sociaux
le nombre de messages il n'y avait plus
depuis hier 20 heures et aujourd'hui 20
heures plus de 115 mille messages avec
41 mille comptes qui utilisent ce
message et vous avez 88000 retweete donc
on peut dire que c'est un mouvement
ce qui est intéressant c'est de regarder
qui sont derrière ces 41 milles et ce
qui se dit en fait ça recouvre beaucoup
de gens aiment beaucoup de réalités
d'abord tous les gens tous les électeurs
de droite ont envie de dire quelque
chose et donc sans moi le 7 mai c'est
une façon de dire maintenant je ne
voterai pas c'est pas que je ne veux pas
que je veux faire passer madame le pen
je considère que puisqu'il ya des gens
qui sont pour monsieur macron qu'ils
votent donc pour lui qui le soutiennent
et puis quelque part on est tranquille
elle ne passera pas donc on peut se
permettre de dire
vous avez aussi des électeurs de gauche
des électeurs de mélenchon qui utilise
cette expression donc ça explique aussi
le volume et puis vous avez aussi des
gens qui utilisent hashtag pour dire aux
gens à aller voter
donc un peu vous dites mais c'est un
mouvement aujourd'hui ça me dérange
c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir que derrière c'est ça c'est cette
expression de si on vote
en fait on va donner nos voix et on va
donner un emmanuel macron un point qui
ne représentera pas la réalité on n'a
pas envie de donner ce poids là et on
est quand même tranquille
marine le pen ne passera pas alors ce
soir c'est vous parler de deux points ça
c'est important créé c'est clair gagner
le second tour pour emmanuel macron
j'allais dire c'est presque une logique
arithmétique sur le papier mais il reste
la politique il faut qu'il arrive à
convaincre sur ce plan là oui il faut
vous savez il ya toujours des courbes
ascendantes et qui retombe
il faut que la courbe continue à monter
qu'elle ne retombe pas avant le vote
quinze jours c'est long finalement qu'on
ne se lasse pas non plus parce que ça
fait quand même des biens sur sa
campagne des très courts tout tout son
parcours a été extraordinairement rapide
et en même temps avec une inflation
médiatique folle ce qui fait que un
homme politique aujourd'hui devient un
objet de consommation et qu'on s'en
lasse come on come on se lasse de tout
et on commet se lasse des gardes et des
amours peut-être il a provoqué un
phénomène quasi amoureux et maintenant
le danger pour lui c'est justement de
l'incarner que cette france d'en haut
parce que ça on est en train de le
répéter en boucle et évidemment le ce
qu'on appelait autrefois le peuple de
droite où le peuple de gauche peut-être
ne s'y retrouve t'il pas dans ce mois en
dehors pour la vue à dîner à la rotonde
après tout avait bien le droit derrière
retombée on avait pensé aux au delà du
nom de la brasserie audio restants mais
le fait qu'on qu'on fait et j'ai même
entendu bordée des confrères discuter du
prix comparés avec
car les besoins notre avis c'était quand
même un affichage des gens d'en haut
finalement et qu'on a déjà vu ailleurs
que le fêter l'accession second tour
d'emmanuel macron c'est pour lui une
énorme victoire c'est parce qu'il ya
quelques mois il ya encore plus quelques
même quelques semaines personne n'y
croyait
donc je comprends la joie le discours
qu'il a fait puis le dîner
ça faisait plus second tour qu'au
premier tour est ce que j'en ai vu ou
sur les réseaux sociaux mais avec mon
prisme c'est que ce n'était pas toujours
très bien passé un d'en bas qui est déjà
gagné pourquoi il répond voter c'est le
fameux son nom était partie de ça c'est
en disant mais puisqu'il a gagné
deuxième tour il a pas besoin de la voix
pour battre madame le pen puisqu'il a
déjà que j'ai en garrigue au delà de la
soirée c'est le discours qui est
important ce vous qui avez le regard est
le recul de l'historien discours comme
celui là un moment important quand même
où il ya le front national qui est
qualifié au second tour il fallait qu'il
y ait un souffle est ce que vous l'avez
senti ce soit lors de ce discours n'est
pas le meilleur qui a été fait par
emmanuel macron dans cette campagne est
incontestable peut-être que ce bercy
était quand même au dessus et il lui
manquait le souffle justement du
rassemblement de deuxième tour alors
c'est vrai que il a beaucoup fait
campagne sur le rempart contre marine le
pen et il lui est plus difficile
aujourd'hui de jouer la carte du
rassemblement
d'autant qu'il vient de prendre un coup
de poignard dans le dos avec le
ralliement le soutien de françois
hollande
un coup de poignard en vo c'est
peut-être exagéré impose mais c'est
quand même peut-être personne n'y fait
attention c'est quoi
mais on peut penser que c'est pas le
meilleur service qui lui est rendu parce
que précisément salle l'associent à la
thématique de manuel hollande
et puis au bilan du quinquennat de
france relever puis à cette france d'en
haut enfin qui est accusé de d'oublier
justement les préoccupations la france
d'en bas mais je dirais que sur un plan
plus politique l'équation où les
équilibres de mettre des manuels macron
est quand même difficile à trouver parce
que il et defacto obligé de ménager une
partie de la droite qui voit là le soir
même françois fillon jean alain juppé
s'est rallié à lui a décidé de le
soutenir
donc de continuer dans le sens de cette
politique néolibérale qui l'a lancé
enfin qui est très clairement son sa
direction mais en même temps il a en
face de lui
40% de l'électorat qui ont voté pour les
candidats de gauche ou de droite
populiste
cette france d'en bas cette france
malheureuse qui attend du social et donc
pour gagner cette campagne il doit un
peu jouer sur les deux tableaux
c'est une équation qu'il connaissait dès
le départ puisque c'est au fond la
raison même de son de son rassemblement
mais c'est quand même là en l'occurrence
très difficile dans les quinze jours va
revenir sur ce jeu d'équilibré sont va
écouter parce que vous en avez parlé
sans surprise françois hollande qui a
apporté son soutient emmanuel macron
extrait d'une courte allocution
aujourd'hui du présent république
la présence de l'extrême droite fait une
nouvelle fois courir un risque pour
notre pays
il y a d'abord son histoire sa longue
histoire
il y a aussi ses méthodes ses liens avec
des groupes extrémistes partout en
europe mais il ya surtout les
conséquences qu'aurait la mise en oeuvre
de son programme sur la vie de notre
pays
enfin face à la menace terroriste qui
exige
la solidarité est également la cohésion
de notre pays
l'extrême droite diviserait profondément
la france stigmatiserait une partie de
nos concitoyens au regard de leur
origine ou de leur religion
elle mettrait en cause les libertés et
les principes qui fondent la république
voilà pourquoi fasse un tel risque
il n'est pas possible de se taire pas
davantage de se réfugier dans la
différence la mobilisation s'impose mais
également la clarté des choix pour ma
part je voterai emmanuel macron super
voilà pourquoi on a décidé de passer un
extrait un peu plus lent que prévu
christine clerc tout simplement pour que
je puisse vous poser la question en
fonction de ce que vous avez entendu on
a l'impression que c'est d'abord une
attaque contre le front national ce qui
les incarnent ce qui représente que
plutôt qu'un soutien vraiment avec la
ferveur pour emmanuel macron oui
d'ailleurs l'avoir tombe c'est à peine
si on entend le maquereau oui bien sûr
il a estimé qu'il était de son devoir à
tous c'est vrai ça les salles est sans
doute son devoir simplement savoir ne
pèse plus je crois ce qui avait posé
c'était son départ les gens qui prend
fin que son renoncement les gens qu'ils
renoncent ou qui parle et qui ensuite
reviennent parce que malgré tout il
revient à ce moment là c'est pas très
bien perçue
enfin évidemment il est là il faut bien
qu'ils prennent encore la parole et qui
façon son métier de l'eca lui il l'a
prise par armand jallet gérance que
c'était son devoir quand même pour lui
dire essayons de voir là dessus vous lui
donner crédit eux par contre il ya eu
une réaction obtenue non réaction à ce
que ça vous a tous surpris à faire un
tour de table à roanne olemps jean luc
mélenchon des pierres on peut comprendre
que là la défaite la mauvaise entre
guillemets mais certains ont du mal à
comprendre qu'ils ne prennent pas
position j'aimais bien enfin bien sûr je
crois que tout le monde attendait ce que
jean luc mélenchon
dénonce le front national je crois que
par sa position il ne fait que confirmer
un que il a des relations qui sont plus
qu'étrange avec la fonctionnement
démocratique
et deux qu'il est plus proche du parti
du front national que d autre que d
autres partis et son attitude d'hier
soir a été honnêtement assez
incompréhensible et assez peu estimable
est ce que c'est vraiment parce qu'il
est proche
en tout cas sur son programme certains
programmes de fondasol ou est ce que
c'est parce que jean garrigues
il n'a rien comment avec le programme
des manuels bacon que vous avez décrit
tout à l'heure néo libéral oui en tout
cas que sa rhétorique veut nous faire
penser que le programme des manuels
maquereau et le programme d' un suppôt
du grand capital ce qui d'un point de
vue d'historien est une contrevérité et
une disqualification
je dirais inacceptable à mes yeux
l'historien de toute une partie des
électeurs de gauche qui ont voté pour
emmanuel macron et on al impression qu
au fond l'essentiel dans cette campagne
pour jean luc mélenchon s'étaient
d'abattre le parti socialiste et de
prendre une revanche sur un parti qui ne
l'avaient pas compris ça c'est fait
qu'ils n'avaient pas vu en lui le
nouveau françois mitterrand qu'il
espérait être et on sent bien qu'il y a
à la fois se depi mais c'est vrai aussi
que ce dépit est ce cette prise de
position
elle s'appuie sur un élément politique
alors plus tout à fait tangibles qui est
c'est vrai la proximité d'un certain
nombre de ces thématiques avec celles du
front national pour la sq il faut pas
parlé tout à l'heure de deux fils cadet
des jumeaux sur le plan économique on
l'a entendu certains l'ont écrit est
faux mais quand même ils sont quand même
assez proche même si là les les origines
la culture le jeudi l'intention est
évidemment très très différentes mais
seul le rapport entre les extrêmes
droites et gauches c'est une question
qui se pose dans la vie politique
française depuis de la sphère à cognac
et ça va continuer donc il ya aide
defacto notamment sur la question de
l'europe sur les questions de politique
étrangère
les rapports avec la russie 2
lire poutine il ya quand même beaucoup
de choses qui rapproche mais surtout ce
qui rapproche fondamentalement c'est
c'est les gens qui s'adressent voilà
cette france malheureuse ou insoumise à
laquelle il s'adresse tous les deux j'ai
envie d'ajouter une chose
cette france à laquelle il s'adresse et
il lui a dit qu'elle était grande
il a dit aux français que l'écouté
qu'ils étaient grands il avait beaucoup
monter en niveau si je veux dire
intellectuelle spirituelle littéraire
souligné aux en temps c'était victor
hugo par maman moi je pensais à malraux
de gaulle parce qu'il ya eu un fameux
meeting à marseille et il y avait des
accents de ça donc je pense qu'il se
considérait aussi trois niveaux
au-dessus de macrohori doit être pour
lui un motif non grata bien bon et très
très au dessus du hameau évidemment et
tout à coup il se trouve ramené en
dessous c'est c'est un choc
il se considère comme très supérieures à
ces gens là et il a eu une véritable
rencontre amoureuse avec le pommeau
d'ailleurs ça se terminait toujours par
un parent un verre par une tournure
politique
ça l'est beaucoup plus loin que le puck
rares et a fini sa déception selon vous
pourrez intégrer sur les réseaux sociaux
sur les réseaux coréenne
c'est à dire qu'en fait ils ont d'abord
les militants et les soutiens de jean
luc mélenchon et des électeurs ont
rencontré cette grandeur donc eux et ils
n'ont pas vécu du tout comme une
trahison bien au contraire ils sont
plutôt en phase avec le non choix c'est
pas force d'abord en lisant il a exprimé
la même façon mais parce qu'on lise
assez que il
il était déçu et qu'il y croyait comme
ces militants donc il a sans doute eu ce
moment un peu difficile et après c'est
pas en fait on lisait beaucoup de toutes
les façons on sait qu'il est contre
marine le pen puisque d'ailleurs il a
été dans le nord pour se battre contre
elle donc c'est pas un sujet donc il n'a
pas à le redire et et en plus il a
expliqué en disant ne se sent les
militants qui vont se réunir qui vont
prendre la décision ensemble donc ça a
été plutôt appréciée par les militants
il n'est pas vue comme les
éditorialistes et les intéressant de
voir la nature
c'est bien ce qui fait il a raison nous
allons décider nous avons le temps n'est
pas obligé de se précipiter dès le
premier soir sur sestrières la question
se pose sur la puisque vous parlais tout
à l'heure d'un pack de la prise de
parole de françois hollande au delà et
ronan l'impact des consignes de vote
encore aujourd'hui à notre époque on va
parler tout à l'heure de la droite mais
est ce que ces consignes de vote
aujourd'hui dans l'électorat je pense
pas qu'ils aient desquels ils
fonctionnent comme des ordres mais c'est
quand même des guides
c'est du pur d un salon des lecteurs qui
peuvent se poser des questions à savoir
ce qu'ils font de savoir que des
personnalités politiques auxquels ils
font confiance vont voter telle façon
que ça a du sens la consigne de vote qui
consiste à dire voter comme ça ça marche
pas celle qui est à titre personnel ou
moi en tant que responsable politique je
voudrais telle et telle façon je pense
que ça peut servir de repères et c'est à
ce titre que j'en conclu jean luc
mélenchon est critiqué parce que un
responsable politique doit faire des
choix et quand bien même l'offre qu'il
est vendu le satisfait pas on attend lui
qui dit voilà moi si j'étais responsable
si j'étais en position de décider
je choisirai telle ou telle personne ne
l'a pas fait et vous avez dit donc
donner son avis pour que ce soit clair
il ya le risque aujourd'hui d'une france
ingouvernable est ce que c'est le cas on
va voir cela parce que la question se
pose quelle majorité parlementaire pour
le prochain président quel qu'il soit
ces élections législatives peuvent
vraiment ressembler à un casse-tête les
détails avec julie hull emmanuel macron
où marine le pen
quel que soit le futur président sa
majorité parlementaire semble très loin
d'être acquise
oui l'étape des législatives s'annoncent
délicates
côté front national le mode de scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours lui a toujours
été défavorable le parti ne possédant
aucun soutien partisan
le fn espère pourtant attirer une partie
des électeurs de droite avec le secret
espoir de former un groupe à l'assemblée
entre 25 et 50 députés très loin des 290
sièges nécessaires pour gouverner
côté emmanuel macron la moitié des
candidats aux législatives devrait être
issu de la société civile comme il s'y
était engagé des nouveaux visages auquel
devraient se rajouter des élus sortants
de gauche et de droite
en face le parti socialiste risque
d'éclater en deux groupes pro et anti
macron les républicains eux en temps de
faire des législatives un match retour
objectif sauver un maximum de députés
dans l'espoir notamment de créer les
conditions d'une cohabitation peu
importe pour emmanuel macron qui a déjà
déclaré qu'il était prêt à gouverner par
ordonnances permettant de faire adopter
des projets de loi sans passer par un
vote
et maintenant la peur le risque c'est
celui créé sicaires d'une france
ingouvernable quel que soit le candidat
on joue pas se faire peur c'est nommé
hôtel on fait comme si elle avait été
gouvernable auparavant demandé de me
lalande hier françois hollande s'il
avait une majorité pour gouverner
bon il aurait peut-être pu la voir s'il
avait tendu la main aux cintres en face
à c'est une histoire passée mais ça fait
très longtemps que la france est
ingouvernable enfin il ya 2 ou 3 go
chacun trois droites où ça se croisent
se combinent et puis et puis il ya le
problème des présidents de l'année des
présidents qui lorsqu'ils sont candidats
font des promesses qu'ils ne peuvent pas
tenir donc une partie de leur électorat
se détournent 2 c'est pas une histoire
nouvelle on a l'air de découvrir ça je
pense que ce qui attend macron n'est pas
n'est pas tellement plus difficile que
sauf qui va trouver peut-être les
caisses vides un prix du pétrole qui va
monter des taux d'intérêt qui vont
monter mais le problème de la majorité
et là je peux aussi la fille s'il est
pas plus qu'avant je connaissais la
question du manque de cohérence jusqu'à
la cohabitation jean garrigues à ce que
la logique quand même vous dresse notre
vème république que les français
légitime le président qu'il vienne
des nuits qu'il y ait une dynamique
législative qui suivent la dermite
présidentielle oui c'est c'est au fond
la logique qui avait poussé d'ailleurs
françois mitterrand 1981 à dissoudre
pour avoir une majorité parlementaire
conforme la fameuse vague rose et qui a
été un élément très important d'ailleurs
de dire et de mise en d'installation à
vie politique française de cette idée de
majorité mais comme le disait fort
justement christine clerc ça n'a pas
empêché ce système de la vème république
avec son alternance avec son système
bipolaire pas d'être d'aboutir à rien
c'est à dire à des échecs permanent sur
les grands enjeux de vie politique
française il faut donc je pense se poser
un problème sur le fonctionnement
sinon sur le fonctionnement de nos
institutions en tout cas la manière dont
on fait rouler ses institutions
et c'est d'ailleurs ce diagnostic là qui
a été fait par emmanuel macron c'est pas
un mystère s'il a écarté la logique des
partis et s'il a voulu construire une
nouvelle majorité
alors est ce que cette majorité est ce
que construire une majorité de ceux-ci
une majorité d'idées majorité de 2,2
programme peut se faire dans le cadre
des institutions de la vème république
évidemment ça sera très difficile les
ans pareil en session paris mais au fond
est-ce que les résultats seront pires
que ce qu'on a connu jusqu'à présent où
on a bien vu regardez cette majorité de
françois hollande qui était complètement
divisé avec les avec les frondeurs parce
qu'elle reposait sur sur une ambiguïté
fondamentale sur une unité factice de la
gauche
eh bien on peut se dire que là au moins
les choses peut-être au fond seront plus
claires à ce qu on essaiera de nos
bêtises alors et hors des partis dans ce
we non c'est pas votre avis à rome non
je ne dirais pas l'ordre les parkings ce
qui me semble c'est que au moins
jusqu'aux législatives
résultat les et yvon va rester dans un
clivage gauche droite enfin macm macron
pardon macron sa gauche sa droite qui
aura pas de ralliements majeur avant les
résultats des législatives notamment à
droite les cno les différents
responsables de la droite attendons
attendront les résultats les natifs pour
savoir s'ils peuvent aller négocier un
poste en étant puissant ou non devenir
premier ministre ou pas et on sait
qu'ils commencent à discuter et que ça y
est des sondages de part et d'autre
est-ce que emmanuel macron pourra
gouverner plus facilement que moi au
moins facilement pendant que les autres
je ne sais pas ce qui est sûr c'est que
s'il fait une majorité d'idées il ya
quand même
il va avoir probablement débuter en
marche qui sont des députés général qui
dit que ce seront des députés nouveaux
corps ont aussi l'ex pas l'expérience
politique qui vont rocchi à la première
crise vont retourner sur les marchés et
se faire insulter son par les électeurs
et c'est pas nécessairement quelque
chose de très agréable qu'on entend
quand on n'a pas l'habitude même quand
on a l'habitude des députés à l'approché
de prochaines élections ce qu'était
droite
enfin ceux qui sont à droite pourront
peut-être se revenir plus sur leur camp
lors qu'en pour marquer leur différence
donc là la majorité d'idées elle est
possible mais c'est un c'est une crête
qui difficile à tenir qui est sûrement
probable dans les dents au début du
quinquennat sur un quinquennat entier
j'ai des doutes tel cas ça sent paris et
son défi je ne sais pas si sur les
réseaux sociaux on discute déjà
élections législatives est ce que le cap
est déjà sur ces élections-là de la
bataille est déjà enclenché pour la
raison que je vous ai vu qu à quelques
pour les internautes le match est déjà
plié donc c'est une question de savoir
quel sera le pourcentage mais personne
n'envisage que madame le pen passe donc
ils sont déjà en train de perdre et
déficit législatives des enjeux et puis
après les réseaux sociaux c'est du local
est en fait les des discussions le câble
donc là on va avoir sur les législatives
des débats qui seront riches en
particulier sur facebook
oui il ya une hypothèse qui est qui est
plausible c'est que précisément c'est ce
qu'on le disait tout à l'heure il ya une
cohabitation ce que parce que la
victoire
je dirais la victoire du camp de la
droite de la droite républicaine aux
élections législatives
au fond c'est l'hypothèse elle
plus plausible en tout cas qui a été
fait depuis très longtemps par par tous
les sondeurs elle était déjà lié et
j'allais dire programmés et d'ailleurs
l'élection d'alain juppé ou de françois
fillon aurait été le prélude à ce à ce
vaste avait ce vaste reconquête
légistatives de la droite donc il n'est
pas impossible qu'on se retourner les
situations la france serait moins un
gouvernable pas forcément mais c'est à
dire peut-être ma question est ce que
les paires de la paire de cohabitation
qu'on a connu dans notre histoire
contemporaine c'était une période entre
guillemets heureuse où la france a à
marcher sur ses deux pieds bien écouté
alors je sais que toute une partie des
observateurs de la classe politique n'a
pas de mots assez durs pour vilipender
les périodes de cohabitation
j'observe quand même que c'est vrai dans
une conjoncture économique favorable
la dernière cohabitation lionel jospin
jacques chirac a plutôt donné des bons
résultats en termes de lutte contre le
chômage de croissance économique etc et
même de réformes sociétales
donc après tout est ce qu'une telle
cohabitation alors c'est vrai que là
elle serait très spécial cette
cohabitation parce que elle elle
voudrait dire qu'un camp privé de son
chef de françois fillon qui est décidé
plus ou moins de se mettre en retrait
pratiquerait ou mettrez en oeuvre une
politique qui serait le fruit de
transaction de dernière minute entre les
différentes familles de la droite et ce
au détriment d'un président fleuret
public et lui parce qu'il était
l'incarnation de la transgression et qui
serait donc j'irai condamné à être une
semaine comme ça s'est jamais vu comme
une habitation dans la foulée de la
présidentielle
ça se voit deux ans après la
présidentielle mais chaque fois chaque
fois le camp qui a perdu espère
évidemment qu'il va rattraper en gagnant
législatives depuis depuis mitterrand en
81 chaque fois il dit on va on va
rééquilibrer mais non parce que je crois
que le peuple donne donne le pouvoir un
président et dans la foulée tu l'a voulu
et vient entre le donne et voilà on va
te mettre à l'épreuve est maintenant
donnée
des volumes amène ce que tu sais faire
et tu pourras même pas dire quand amélie
bâtons dans les roues quant à envoyer
une autre majorité ensuite donc vas-y
vas-y gouverne pendant deux ans et moins
et quand on s'appuyait déjà sur
l'armature d'un parti qui a une
expérience de des campagnes de la vie
gouvernementale etc
mais là on est dans une situation
totalement inédite alors on pourrait
revenir à 950 et il ya quand même des
gens excessifs et la royaume candidats
seront déjà étoilé il n'y a que la
moitié partie des derniers que l'on lit
c'est qu'en fait ils sont déjà dans les
récits sociaux oui et ils disent mais
qui sont ces députés dont on nous parle
en fait du coup ils disent mais c'est
difficile aussi de se projeter et ils
sont peut-être prêts à donner un élan
positif mais arrête paris se pose la
question pourquoi est ce qu'on doit
attendre on ne sait pas qui se sera on
nous dit qu'il aura la moitié d'hommes
et on ne sait pas donc chacun 10 mm
localement je n'aime pas le nom de la
personne qui va ça va venir patients en
attente
je crois assez à l'aco à la cohérence du
vote des français
mais pour autant c'est ce qu'a dû à une
cohabitation je sais pas mais c'est pas
pour autant que ça va la cohérence va
conduire à une majorité claire pour le
président de l'as pour le futur
président la république si c'est
emmanuel macron parce que comme je
disais tout à l'heure on voit qu'il ya à
peine la mouffe à un peu plus de la
moitié de son électorat qu'à voter par
conviction vous avez beaucoup
d'électeurs de droite qui ont voté parce
qu'ils étaient déçus par françois fillon
est ce qu'ils vont revoter pour en
marche pour vous passer à droite une
partie des électeurs de gauche et ça
jouera comme vous le dites alors aussi
au niveau local en fonction des bourses
à des candidatures locales
eh bien nous verrons tout cela que des
majorités divisé alors pour tous n'est
ce pas merci à vous merci pour ce débat
cette analyse on va continuer bien sûr à
en parler ce soir avec cette question
quelle ligne quels projets et quel
leader à droite le parti se réveille
groggy
françois fillon l'avait dit tout à
l'heure tire sa révérence les
républicains appellent à voter contre
marine le pen est bien sur ce sujet le
match des idées va opposer dans quelques
instants
anne levade juriste professeur au droit
à l'académicien jean marie rouart à
tacite
on arrive à simplon là où tout a
commencé
salut tout le monde frédéric bardot est
le cofondateur de simplon une école
d'informatique gratuites destinés aux
individus en situation précaire ou à bas
revenus mike avant il avait travaillé
dans la restauration
là on parle kolb on parle
formation on va chercher des gens qui
savent même pas ce que c'est que la
programmation informatique ans suscite
des vocations
ordina en fait tu peux le faire c'est
vous la france à la découverte de
l'école simplon demain à 16h30 ce public
sénat
c'est
la france compte 58 réacteurs nucléaires
sur son territoire mais communiquer sur
le risque nucléaire reste compliquée
tant les intérêts économiques sont
puissants au point de passer sous
silence certains incidents parfois il
peut y avoir un écart en communication
certainement pas en transparence et donc
la communication effectivement c'est un
travail toujours délicat de bien se
comprendre et de bonnes données de biens
de l'information nous y travaillons tous
les jours et donc du coup supporters de
type arabe vous m'expliquez pas ce qui
s'est passé pour fessenheim normes oms
ait fait non vous voulez pas me parler
de fessenheim non
attention risque majeur jeudi à 17h30
sur public sénat et bienvenue à vous si
vous nous rejoignez à l'instant nous
sommes en direct c'est votre émission on
voit plus loin pour évoquer à présent
que cette autre campagne de second tour
qui a déjà démarré et déjà les
législatives sont en ligne de mire la
droite éliminer la droite fracturée mais
la droite peut être ressuscitée en vue
de ces élections législatives c'est en
tous les cas ce qu'elle espère en
attendant françois fillon se retire et
tous se réorganise on en parle être nos
invités ce soir anne levade bonsoir
bonsoir juriste professeur de droit
public vous avez présidé la haute
autorité pour la primaire de la droite
et du centre
je le précise parce qu'on a quand même
parlé tout à l'heure des primaires et de
leurs résultats et face à vous et avec
nous l'auteur et académicien jean-marie
roy rebond soir alors la droite les
républicains cherchent à éviter
l'implosion au lendemain de leur défaite
un bureau politique s'est tenue tout à
l'heure françois fillon a tiré sa
révérence les détails avec mounir ce
aussi un bureau politique qui tourne au
numéro d'équilibriste pour les
républicains
pendant deux heures les ténors ont
débattu pour arrêter une position
commune
pas de front républicain le parti assure
le service minimum face au front
national
l'abstention ne peut être un choix
nous appelons à voter contre marine le
pen pour la faire battre au second tour
de l'élection présidentielle
elle refuse d'appeler à voter pour
emmanuel macron une précaution de
langage assumer même si une partie des
cadres a conscience que les électeurs ne
seront pas dupes ils sont combien
candidats y en avait 2 si vous dites
faire battre le front national ça
revienne quand même bien à dire que
c'est ma grande joie 10 mai parce que
on ne peut pas avec des élections
législatives immédiatement derrière les
présidentielles mettre dans la
difficulté nos candidats aux
législatives
ce consensus ne satisfait pas tout le
monde plusieurs responsables comme
christian estrosi au xavier bertrand
aurait souhaité que le parti assume la
consigne de vote
à la différence de laurent wauquiez qui
estimé cette position suicidaire
cet épisode est le premier de cette
phase de reconstruction où on aperçoit
déjà deux lignes se dessiner avant de
parler de la suite et des éventuels de
ligne qui se dessine une même question
dans quel état ne vas te réveiller la
droite aujourd'hui forcément groggy par
ce que c'est vrai que les sondages
étaient très incertains que certains
avaient des doutes que les uns et les
autres je crois ce rendez bien compte
sur le terrain que vous faire à mesure
de la campagne avec des choses qui
passaient plus ou moins bien
pour autant une défaite
nécessairement c'est toujours difficile
à accepter et puis j'allais dire à
digérer parce que il faut évidemment à
la fois faire le bilan
le faire très vite puisqu'il faut réagir
dans la perspective d'un deuxième tour
qui est qui dans 15 jours je crois que
la formule a été utilisé il y aura
plusieurs reprises d'un 21 avril à
l'envers par référence à ce qui s'est
passé il ya 15 ans et c'est évidemment
ça quand même la première fois que la
droite républicaine
partis de gouvernement n'est pas au
deuxième tour d'une élection
présidentielle depuis 1965 donc ça ne
peut qu'être un choc pour eux et puis
c'est vrai aussi que depuis plusieurs
années maintenant il ya quand même des
tensions internes au parti un déficit de
leadership
bref une situation qui ne peut pas se
résoudre en huit jours
mais face à laquelle il faut quand même
réagir si effectivement ils veulent dans
la perspective des législatives arrivé à
reconstituer quelque chose il faut faire
le bilan de quoi de qui jean marie
rouart je prends deux exemples eric
woerth qui attribue cette défaite
directement à françois fillon et puis
gérald darmanin qui dit c'est une
question de ligne de projets on s'est
trompé sur ça est-ce que c'est peut-être
les deux à la fois où l'un des deux
d'abord témoin je crois que si la droite
pour faire son autocritique
ça serait d'abord et on l'avait
quasiment prévu faire la critique de la
prime est franche choisissant la
primaire n'a droit s'est enfermé mais
elle le savait c'est extraordinaire elle
avait conscience que ce qui avait pu
marcher pour la gauche ne lui
correspondait absolument pas c'est le
contraire des institutions du général de
gaulle et c'était vraiment prendre
énormément de risques parce que
justement ce qu'elle a dit restant dans
les institutions dans son esprit c'est
le grand rassemblement c'est pas la
division
or la primaire 1 ci dessus c'est
l'institutionnalisation des divisions et
on l'a bien vu
on a bien vu à quel point déjà pour la
gauche avait été extrêmement néfaste à
françois hollande qui avait porté
pendant très longtemps les critiques de
martine aubry
eh bien cette fois ci on a bien compris
que cette ces attaques qui ont pu avoir
lieu pendant les primaires ont été
extrêmement néfaste donc je pense que la
principale obstructive d'ailleurs
ce qui est formidable aussi est ce qu'il
ya d'étonnant dans la dans la victoire
de macron c'est que il a fait exploser
les prix mais il n'y aura plus jamais de
prix mais parce que maintenant qu'on a
vu que finalement les deux seuls
candidats qui avaient une chance de
l'emporter était à la fois mélenchon est
à la fois un croquis tous les deux
avaient refusé de participer à la
primaire
on peut dire adieu la primaire mais 7,7
souffrait revenir à un moment sur
mélenchon
ce qui me paraît formidable c'est son
coup d'état à la fois démocratique légal
est sympathique c'est à dire c'était
vraiment un coup d'état puisqu'il a
complètement bouleversé le système d'une
façon complètement légale et
démocratique
on va parler de jean luc mélenchon je
reste quand même sur la première partie
de votre argumentaire qui est là la fin
de la primaire vous l'avez acte et vous
même en votre nom personnel et s'y ce
soir c'est le cas le vad
cet antidote contre les divisions est un
poison qui a précipité les deux grands
partis aujourd'hui alors je j'ai un vrai
désaccord avec avec ce qui vient d'être
dit je dis juste une nouvelle fois je
l'aï dit à plusieurs reprises que bien
qu ayant organisé la primaire je fais
pas partie de ceux qui étaient fascinés
par les primaires et qui voulait mettre
des primaires partout j'ai même toujours
été assez réservé deux manière générale
sur l'exercice et sur l'importation en
france de quelque chose qui fonctionne
aux états unis cela étant si je regarde
le cas de la france est uniquement de la
droite
s'il n'y avait pas eu de primaire
premières observations on aurait eu
plusieurs candidats à droite et
plusieurs candidats à droite
à mon avis et c'était bien ça la
difficulté c'est qu'il y avait pas de
candidat qui s'impose est par lui-même
s'il n'y avait eu plusieurs candidats à
droite on sait bien que la situation
aurait été largement aussi compliquée
qu'elle l'est aujourd'hui
la deuxième chose c'est que moi je suis
convaincu et plus je réfléchis
maintenant avec un peu de recul à cette
primaire plus j'en suis convaincu que
c'est un peu comme le thermomètre est la
fièvre la primaire elle est venue à un
moment donné ou à droite comme à gauche
d'ailleurs
les partis de gouvernement allait très
mal et je crois que nos partis
traditionnels de gouvernement vont très
mal parce que la démocratie
représentative va très mal et qui a une
mise en cause de ceux qui gouvernent
maintenant depuis des décennies qui
n'apparaissent plus crédible dans
l'opinion
la preuve c'est que quelqu'un venu de
nulle part emmanuel macron en un an
arrive a explosé que jean luc mélenchon
d'une certaine manière pas tout à fait
venu de nulle part mais en tout cas avec
un discours très anti système ce qui
évidemment est par ailleurs préoccupant
arrive aussi à émerger d'une manière
phénoménale et le problème il est
toujours le même on a prêté à la
primaire des vertus magiques qu'elle n'a
pas parce que ça n'est qu'une procédure
et je crois que le fond du problème
c'est que la droite et la gauche
républicaine je n'ai pas la solution
j'en suis désespéré d'ailleurs parce que
j'aimerais l'avoir pour la droite et la
gauche aurait pu perdre au pardon de
vous contredire
d'autant plus que vous avez eu un rôle
formidable est finalement là la seule
qui ait survécu à la primaire avec
l'accord unanime à rejeter tous les
autres fait éliminer à glace à la plante
d'aborder la saison le problème vous
vous gardez les réputations formule 1
mais je pense que regardez comme elle me
passer vous nous dites que cette
primaire savait faux très bien
fonctionné pendant 50 ans sans aucune
primaire et la droite avait parfaitement
réussi à trouver des candidats qu'ils
s'opposeraient au bonheur y avait des
figures et à partir du moment où il n'y
avait pas levé les deux heures avec les
prix mais parce qu'à ce moment là vous
suscitez des petits leaders qui avoir
dans la vie remplie ce paysage et je
crois moi je crois qu'il ya un côté
darwinien dans les élections
présidentielles et dans les instituts
dont assez crûment public
c'est le plus fort qui l'emportent et on
voit très bien que le plus fort avait
toujours réussi à l'emporter
une question aujourd'hui la droite
j'allais dire saisons maintenant second
tour et en vue des législatives
quel leader s'imposerait selon vous
est-ce qu'un leader qui s'appelait
attendez on les a ils ont été fusillés
par l'imprimé c'est sûr que maintenant
c'est très difficile mais c'est ccc la
cause elle est dans les prix mais c'est
vrai que maintenant mais je pense que
tout le monde le dit la droite est en ce
moment match était majoritaire en france
et donc elle devrait en bonne logique
mais ça on sait pas ce qu'il veut quelle
est la logique dans le domaine politique
et pas toujours au rendez vous eh bien
elle devrait pouvoir avoir une chance
aux législatives
et c'est d'ailleurs tout le problème
c'est de savoir est-ce que
macron va pouvoir avoir une majorité ou
est-ce que servent à s'enfuir mais il
est lui même une cohabitation à lui tout
seul puisque à la fois la fois il va le
robert hue à madelin c'est déjà une
cohabitation est ce qu'on va pouvoir
rajouter une autre que l'habitation et
de cohabitation pourrais vous dire que
la droite en ce moment va de nathalie
kosciusko morizet à sens commun oui
escapade à droite également du droit
visitez pas une cohabitaient l'analyse
explosion novatrice que vous êtes
d'accord sur ce que dit jean marc
ayrault avant les profondeurs du pays et
à droite ce pays là c'est ce qu'on dit
on lit le pays est à droite
c'est dans le temps c'est compliqué
parce que tout le monde s'accorde à dire
depuis maintenant plusieurs années que
l'ensemble des partis se droitise alors
les parties très à droite extrême droite
is et que malgré tout la gauche est
plutôt plus droitiser qu'elle ne l'était
auparavant
je n'aime pas beaucoup cette formule
aller évidemment simplificatrice mais
c'est vrai que il ya plus grand chose en
commun avec le paysage politique dit ya
20 ou 30 ans en arrière
la deuxième chose c'est qu'on a pu
penser aussi que la france était
majoritairement à droite lorsque et
rendront leurs grâces ils ne se sont pas
trompés à l'occasion de ce premier tour
les sondages immédiatement après la
primaire de la droite semblait
effectivement tracer une trajectoire
fulgurante pour françois fillon qui
était crédité de plus de 30% des
intentions de vote
au lendemain de la primaire ce qui n'a
jamais été le cas de benoît hamon alors
que pourtant il y avait guère que un
mois et demi d'écart entre les deux
primaires donc on pouvait penser qu'ils
avaient effectivement 7 7 lignes de
force
alors maintenant la vraie question
effectivement que doit se poser la
droite
d'abord moi je voudrais insister c'est
que je suis je dois dire assez inquiètes
de voir que tout le monde considère que
ça y est marine le pen est battu
j'en suis assez inquiète parce que je
veux pas j'espère ne pas être un oiseau
de mauvais augure mais le deuxième tour
et dans un peu moins de 15 jours un
week-end de pont qui plus est où jean
viendrait presque à espérer qu'il ne
fera pas beau et que les gens ne
penseront pas que comme l'affairé fait
ils peuvent partir tranquillement et
revenir pour voir ce qui se sera passé
et donc je pense que la manière dont
emmanuel macron va faire campagne
pendant ces quinze jours et évidemment
déterminante et chacun
me semble-t-il dans la classe politique
s'il entend que ce soit mme emmanuelle
macron qui l'emportent dois le dire le
dire clairement et sans relâche tout
simplement pour éviter qu'ils aient une
abstention qui soit 16 que ce front
républicain il n'est pas encore il n'est
pas un peu fatigué flétri musée c'est
pas alors c'est à peu près ce qu'a dit
marine le pen je peux en train de vous
dire là des pourris voilà je suis et
d'autres arguments pour vous poser la
question qualificatifs moi j'aime pas
cette formule de front républicain parce
qu'elle est à l état j'allais dire elle
a été discrédité en tant que formule en
revanche est la réalité - du sens elle a
du sens dans la mesure où mes mais je
l'avais dit là encore une des raisons
pour lesquelles j'ai accepté de
m'occuper d'une primaire et j'avais dit
à l'époque que j'aurais fait la même
chose pour le parti socialiste parce que
mon attachement viscéralement
républicain m'inciter à tout faire pour
que marine le pen ne soit pas au 2e mais
vous dit anne levade elle a du sens jean
marais à voir quel est le sens quand on
est juste voté manuel macron est ce
qu'il faudrait pas davantage justifiée
expliqué consigne de vote il argumenté
pas seulement dire non surtout pas le
front national c'est tout moi je crois
aussi que c'est en effet cette cette
façon d'idéologie c'est le parti de
marine le pen n'est pas une façon de
combattre et c'est pour ça que je trouve
que chez les républicains
la tendance qui pousse madame kosciusko
morizet ou alain juppé
justement à à aller vers vers macro et
et a entamé un combat idéologique entre
marine le pen n'est pas le bon et je
pense que celui de sarkozy était le
meilleur
c'est à dire essayer de faire venir
c'est pas normal qui est un parti
d'extrême droite qui fasse 20%
c'est pas normal et le but je crois pour
l'avenir parce que si j'allais carey
fait qu'elle est là le la stratégie
nicolas sarkozy puisque pour certains
c'était aller jusqu'à demie aller sur
les terres du front national ni mais le
front national pour ramener ces
électeurs c'est cela qui s'était pas mis
mais non non attention non c'est
or la charente bon lundi pour l'attaqué
dont je ne crois pas du tout ce n'est
pas lui mais c'est répondre à cette
question très ancienne posée par laurent
fabius qui était de dire le lepénisme
pose de bonnes questions mais donne de
mauvaises réponses
vous savez très content c'est vraiment
c'est pas être le pénis que de dire que
en effet le parti de marine le pen a
posé un certain nombre de questions sur
la sécurité et sur l'immigration sur
l'emploi qui étaient des questions qui
se posent à tout le monde puisque le
débat s'est finalement c'est adapté sur
sur l'ailé les lignes lancée par le
front national
donc je pense si on ne résout pas à ces
questions là on verra progresser le
parfait le parti de marine le pen et on
risque de le voir à la prochaine
présidentielle partager quasiment la
même j'allais dire crainte à pascal bats
a rejoint ce que dit jean marié revoir
si certains français vont se
désintéresser de ce second tour parce
qu'ils vont se dire voilà c'est à qui il
n'y a pas vraiment d'argument pour voter
pour ou contre c'est la voilà c'est là
que je pense moi qu'il y à il ya un
risque à vouloir enjamber le deuxième
tour en considérant que l'enjeu
désormais ces législatives
et c'est manifestement plutôt le choix
qui est en train de faire la droite
je ne sais pas comment les choses vont
se traduire concrètement parce que
encore une fois on est au lendemain au
lendemain du choc et il semble
effectivement le parti socialiste veut y
davantage prendre part à la campagne
mais je crois que ça c'est une vraie
question
cela dit la question des législatives se
pose aussi bien sûr et elle est
parfaitement légitime pour les partis de
gouvernement
même si j'ai tendance à penser que moi
l'hypothèse alors d'abord je parlais pas
de cohabitation parce que quand c'est
simultanée je trouve que c'est un petit
peu différent c'est plus de la cogestion
ce serait une espèce de choix délibéré
et lucide fait par les électeurs de ne
pas donner une majorité au président
qu'ils auraient élu un mois et demi un
mois et demi avant c'est possible mais
ça veut dire que d'emblée il exigerait
du président et des parlementaires
qu'ils cogèrent avec des options
politiques différentes
le pays là où la cohabitation est
davantage la sanction deux ans ou cinq
ans plus tard d'une politique quand
apparaissent à l'époque par les dames du
sortie de cogestion pas de cohabitation
c'est vrai que dans ce en tout cas c'est
un choix simultanée l'euphémisme écoutez
c'est une cohabitation vous appelez vous
employez un autre mot pour dire la même
chose cette année on l'a jamais vu tout
de suite après une élection
présidentielle ce serait on la jouera un
manque de cohérence et un manque de
légitimité donnée au présent et oui mais
parce que c'est l'erreur d'avoir adapté
les en effet le mandat des députés et le
bournot du président un public à celui
des députés
c'était une erreur et là encore c'est
une façon de torpiller les institutions
de la vème et pluie qu'on a essayé de
détricoter et petit à petit et
maintenant on voit le résultat on voir
et le comble ça va être l'intrus à
l'introduction d'après la
proportionnelle et à ce moment là on
rentrera non pas de la 6e république
dans la quatrième république
alors la proportionnelle c'est encore
autre chose de toute façon ne sera pas
applicable lors de ces élections la
norme et reverra jeu ça fait longtemps
qu'elle est promise et pour l'instant
elle n'a jamais été mise en oeuvre le
l'actuel président de la république
devait un style et une dose de
proportionnelle comme il disait ça n'a
pas été fait je ne pense pas que ce soit
lié et dieu sait que je suis critique
sur le quinquennat et sur la
concomitance des calendriers mais là je
crois pas que ce soit lié à ça parce que
en réalité la particularité de la
situation elle tient au fait d'un
candidat que l'on images
une élue à la présidence de la
république et qui n'a pas justement
derrière lui un parti de gouvernement au
sens classique du terme le problème
aurait pu se passer exactement de la
même manière en 2007
si bayrou avait remporté l'élection
présidentielle au moment où lui aussi
faisait une percée assez significative
et d'une certaine façon ce qu'a connu
valéry giscard d'estaing en 74 et 78
n'est pas très différent sauf qu'en 74
après le décès de georges pompidou il
n'ya pas eu d'élections législatives
immédiatement et en 78 on sait bien que
ça s'est joué de peu justement qu'il y
ait une première cohabitation faute
d'avoir un parti qui étaient
majoritaires à l'histoire de l'instance
était quasiment une cohabitation
puisqu'il avait une majorité qui brûlent
partie le détester puisque tu exemple
par une partie de gaulliste qui lui
faisait des reproches et vous savez bien
qu'une partie de son échec
ce n'était de pas avoir fait la
dissolution le voit ramenée à
l'actualité
peut-être juste vous faire réagir sur ce
qu'on pourrait appeler chez eux mais
vraiment des guillemets anne levade ce
phénomène de dégagisme quand même on en
voit dans les yeux on n'a jamais vu
autant de responsables politiques
quand même de premier plan disparaître
disparaître beaucoup ont totalement
retiré lors leur révérence tout est à
reconstruire les cartes sont rebattues
comment vous analyser ce phénomène là de
renverser la table vraiment est ce que
tout change pour que rien ne change au
c'est une vraie volonté de renverser la
table je pense qu'il ya une chose qui
est assez assez frappante on sait que
les jeunes ceux qu'on appelle les 18 35
ans qui est déjà un éventail assez large
mais que les jeunes votent plutôt moins
se désintéressent de la politique et
d'une certaine manière ce qui les a
ramenés un peu aux urnes
c'est justement ce vote entre guillemets
contestataires qui prennent la forme
d'un vote mélenchon ou d'un vote d'un
vote le pen la deuxième chose c'est que
là aussi je crois qu'on change
effectivement d'époque de monde et c'est
le moi j'étais assez frappé je
l'entendais notamment dans
j'ai mes étudiants maison fille quand
françois fillon prenait comme argument
dans la campagne j'ai 36 ans de vie
politique et donc je suis un homme
d'expérience et moi certains de mes
étudiants me disait que j'étais pas nés
au moment où effectivement il commencé
sa vie politique donc je pense que ce
qui longtemps rassuré c'est à dire l'âge
des candidats et est aujourd'hui un
argument d'ailleurs l'élection nicolas
sarkozy et françois hollande d'une
certaine manière ont déjà constitué une
rupture par rapport aux élections
précédentes je laisse de côté valéry
giscard d'estaing ce tte évidemment les
éléments de contexte devait sa cote est
passé de georges pompidou
mais je crois qu'il ya ce rajeunissement
on le voit d'ailleurs ailleurs barack
obama eut l'idée en italie en examen on
voit bien il ya un phénomène quand même
de rien au jour du balancier aux etats
unis quand même 70 autres phénomènes
salaires plus complet c'est vrai qu'il
ya quand même un mouvement effectivement
de volonté alors peut-être aussi que
c'est une génération politique qui est
resté quoi qu'il arrive c'est à dire
qu'il ya rck en dix dates et quels que
soient les aléas de la vie politique
c'est peut-être ça c'est pas tant l'âge
en quelque sorte si la durée je crois
d'ailleurs reproché manuel macron 1 lors
d'un meeting à propos de jean luc
mélenchon avait il dit et jean luc
mélenchon était sénateur quand j'étais
encore au lycée je crois même si oui ça
le jeunisme toujours existé il ya
toujours quelqu'un replié plus je t'ai
certaine expérience je crois la toile
oui mais moi je crois que c'est tient
surtout au fait que le discours
politique est très souvent inaudible
devenu complètement technocratique et en
plus le comportement des grands
responsables est très éloigné des
préoccupations quotidiennes et vous
remarquerez que finalement ce qu'ils ont
fait des scores assez important et
filmant qui ont beaucoup d'adhérents
c'est à la fois mélenchon et marine le
pen qui ont ce discours finalement qui
est très concret qui est très proche des
gens je crois qu'ils ont les tombes et
on a une
un vivier d'hommes politiques qui a fait
de trop brillantes études qui a fait
l'ena qui a fait qui parle un langage
abstrait et qui est qui on a
l'impression qu'ils ont le langage
purement économistes et d'ailleurs
c'était un peu le cas de micron qui a
tout de suite rétabli la balance en
allant même temps vers le roman national
est là mais mais je crains que ce
discours purement économistes ça ne
parle pas aux gens on l'a vu a par
avance à l'épreuve des faits des urnes
c'est la réalité
oui avec quand même un phénomène qui est
vraiment inédit c'est que comme pour les
primaires n'ont pas du tout que je en
face un modèle mais il ya un phénomène
de concentration des voix des électeurs
sur quelques candidats et là c'est la
première fois de l'histoire de la vème
république qu'on a quatre candidats
autour de 20% entre 19 et 24 et que tout
laisse donc ça veut dire 80 % des gens
qui se concentre sur quatre candidats et
sept autres qui sont littéralement
laminé parmi lesquels évidemment benoît
hamon ce qu'est ce qui est la grande
surprise puisque c'est le parti
socialiste mais est ce à cet effet là on
ne connaissait pas on le connaissait
pour deux et puis ensuite quelque chose
de plus diffus en place je voudrais vous
poser une question et je sait pas encore
c'est dire en clair des primaires ou est
ce que finalement ça sur à l'enterrement
de je le regretterai puisque vous ne
serez plus là mais parler longtemps la
primaire ça n'est qu'un mode de
désignation de candidats moi je pense
qu'il faut retenir le mode de
désignation le plus adapté à un moment
donné je ne suis pas certaine je
maintiens que je ne suis pas certaine
que avec un autre mode de désignation la
droite et au deuxième tour aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas ce qu'il en sera dans
cinq ans alors prendre à un autre mais
ici même bailleur alors je voudrais vous
faire réagir quand on découvre ensemble
la revue de presse les unes de vos
quotidiens demain on regarde le figaro
l'ondé de choc macron qui frappe à la
droite et la gauche avaient également
françois fillon vous le voyez plus bas
comment l'élection imperdable est
devenue ingagnable libération avec la
photo de marine le pen ne rien lâcher de
macron qui s'y voit déjà une partie de
la gauche
qui refuse de choisir le barrage anti le
pen s'annonce moins solide qu'en 2002
l'humanité tout ce que fait bouger le
vote
mélenchon premier candidat des jeunes
carton plein dans les villes communistes
et les quartiers populaires mobilisé 10
l'humanité enfin le télégramme la
fracture ont conclu de france où
plusieurs france jean marc hier voir un
nobel
vous savez je crois qu'il y aura
toujours
je crois qu'il y avait que deux france
ça serait les bus pour les relations ça
c'est très bien je crois que maintenant
il y avait au moins quatre ce qui est
vraiment un recul par rapport à ce que
nous avions avant et tu seras skhira
drouot rendra les choses plus difficiles
d'accord pour conclure à nos vannes 4 4
france oui je crois parce qu'on le voit
bien dans chacun de ces territoires il
ya un des quatre candidats qui arrive à
25 28 % des voix et ça c'est très
significatif et ce sera ça définit
prochain reviendra cnic défi assure
merci anthony car pour cette analyse et
c'est le match des idées en quelques
instants le grand entretien avec le
philosophe michel onfray qui a également
suivi même commenté au théâtre la soirée
électorale hier on va en parler avec les
mets d'abord c'est le tour d'horizon de
l'actualité du jour
[Musique]
je vais redevenir un militant de coeur
parmi les autres je vais devoir penser
madiot autrement pensez aussi les plaies
de ma famille c'est par ces mots que
françois fillon a conclu sa prise de
parole devant le bureau politique des
républicains
il estime ne plus être légitime pour
mener la bataille des législatives
marine le pen
et dans de la république est le
président de tous les français et qu'à
ce titre il doit donc rassembler tous
les français alors c'est une conviction
profonde mais il faut maintenant passer
des paroles aux actes et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il m'est apparu
indispensable de me mettre en congé de
la présidence du front national
ce soir je ne suis donc plus la
présidente du front national je suis la
candidate à la présidentielle en france
les deux finalistes de la présidentielle
seront côte à côte demain à la
préfecture de police de paris françois
hollande les a conviés à l'hommage rendu
aux policiers tués en service sur les
champs elysées par un homme se
revendiquant de dèche
marine le pen a confirmé sa présence sur
twitter et l'entourage des manuels
macron assure qu' a priori il sera
présent emmanuel ma cour
pour son premier déplacement depuis sa
qualification au second tour emmanuel
macron est venu déposer une gerbe en
souvenir des victimes du génocide
arménien le candidat explique qu'il est
favorable à une journée de commémoration
inscrite dans le calendrier
manifestation
à l'appel de sos racisme et de plusieurs
syndicats étudiants des centaines de
personnes se sont rassemblées place de
la république à paris pour dire non au
front national et pousser à une
mobilisation massive pour le second tour
il y a finalement j'ai beaucoup de gens
une forme d'évidence que marine le pen
va être battu au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
je tiens à faire remarquer que le second
tour est un second tour assez inédit qui
est un second tour où il y aura sans
doute beaucoup de volatilité et qu'il
n'ya aucune évidence a priori que cette
personne soit battu à droite
[Musique]
à un cheveu des 5% synonymes de
remboursement des frais de campagne
nicolas dupont aignan lance un appel aux
dons pour couvrir une partie des
dépenses de son parti debout la france à
cette semaine pour réunir 300 mille euro
et équilibrer ses comptes avant de les
déposer
les candidats en dessous des 5% sont
remboursés de leurs prêts par l'état à
hauteur de 800 mille 423 euros
polémique
[Musique]
le patron de lafarge holcim payent pour
les agissements de son groupe en syrie
eric olsen démissionne après des mois de
polémiques autour de l'activité du
cimentier en syrie un rapport accuse le
groupe d'avoir maintenu son activité
dans le pays et coopérer avec l'état
islamique entre 2011 et 2014 quand la
guerre faisait rage
le directeur général quittera ses
fonctions le 15 juillet
[Musique]
et tout de suite c'est le grand
entretien pour aller plus loin ce soir
[Musique]
avec un peu plus de recul ce soir on va
analyser ensemble les conséquences du
vote irlandais paysage politique qu'est
ce qui peut vraiment changer avec cette
présidentielle le regard critique du
philosophe ce soir michel onfray bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue alors vous n'avez pas
été spectateurs hier michel onfray de la
soirée électorale puisque vous l'avez
vous même commenté en quelque sorte en
direct et en public depuis le théâtre
antoine à paris
le tout était retransmis sur facebook
live et votre site michel onfray points
comme réagir à chaud 1,6 à l'exercice
allez-y repas habituel pour un
philosophe qui prend toujours du recul
et la distance comment vous l'avez vécu
c'est inhabituel parce qu'on ne les
invite pas et qu' on a toujours les
mêmes qui s'en viennent commenter les
chiffres nouveau même si pendant six
mois ils ont dit tout et n'importe quoi
le contraire de tout les invite à
nouveau et un peu comme avec la météo il
nous donne le temps qu'il a fait hier
avec une extrême précision mais rarement
le temps qu'il va faire demain
donc non je pense que l'oeil est dans la
philosophie un travail sur la longue
durée et des registres des vitesses qui
sont différentes quand je travaille à
des cadences et que j'embrasse ceux de
2000 ans d'histoire évidemment on a
besoin d'un temps long d'un temps de
silence de méditation de travail dans
son bureau bibliothèque etc
et puis après on peut aussi penser
l'actualité on peut penser des choses un
peu chaude
justement en regarder longue durée c'est
à dire que ça me paraît extrêmement
intéressant pour pouvoir voter pour
quelqu'un non pas de se soucier de son
programme parce que c'est quand même la
fois à la séduction que de se soucier de
son passé c'est très intéressant le
passé des gens elle sent pas si ce peut
être aussi le passé souvent un passif
donc quand on a vu des gens qui ont
trahi tout dit contraire de tout qui se
sont alliés avec des gens qui sont
devenus leurs amis puis l'heure et demie
puis etc
on voit à peu près à qui on a affaire
quand le général de gaulle arrive au
pouvoir il derrière lui le 18 juin ça
aide un peu d'autres ont
- passer effectivement un passif souvent
de traîtres et de donc c'est intéressant
ça permet de savoir si vous êtes abstenu
alors premier tour non c'est pas la
vraie raison la vraie raison c'est qu'il
y en a plusieurs mois deux de grosses je
dirais la première c'est qu'en 2005
quand j'ai fait partie de ceux qui ont
voté pour le référendum contre la
formule libérale de l'europe et non pas
contre l'europe
il ya un non massif et en 2008 on nous a
dit vous aurez exactement le même texte
et valéry giscard d'estaing qui dit dans
le point que c'est le même texte
quelques verres gueule qui ont changé la
distance il avait absolument raison
juste pour donner l'impression que tu
étais un autre texte que vous pouvez
dire que formellement c'est un autre
texte
et puis les députés et des sénateurs ont
dit ce que le peuple a voulu nous n'en
voulons pas et nous décidons que de
toute façon ce référendum que vous avez
refusé en fin du mois qu'elle vous avez
répondu par non nous nous y répondons
par oui et vous y aurez droit
j'ai estimé que c'était un coup d'état à
sa manière parce que la souveraineté
existe où le recours au référendum et
puis on obéit au référendum
ou alors on dira je fais un référendum
je souhaite que ce soit oui si c'est non
mettre à la poubelle si c'est oui on le
garde
je me suis dit à partir de ce moment là
le devoir du citoyen non pas les
lecteurs mais le devoir du citoyen qui
est l'homme politique qui est censé nous
représenter
c'est de respecter les décisions qui
sont prises
donc ça c'est la première raison qui
fait que dans la mesure où il ya une
rupture de contrat social je ne suis pas
là sans saper la récente cette première
raison qu'on ne développerait en
quelques instants la deuxième quand vous
dites et on comprend les cicatrices et
les français les portent encore sur ce
référendum cette parole non respectés
mais aujourd'hui vous avez hier des
candidats qui étaient pour partie la
sortie de l'euro factice la deuxième
raison parce que la deuxième raison
c'est que en fait tout a été fait pour
que le goulot d'étranglement arrive à ce
qui s'est passé là c'est à dire qu'au
bout du compte on nous a dit il y a des
grands candidats des petits candidats
pourquoi les grands son tigre en
pourquoi une petite sont-ils petit ces
taux n'ont regardé les petits candidats
sont tous des gens qui sont contre lui
la formule libérale de l'europe droulin
et tous ceux qui sont des grands
candidats sont tous des gens qui sont
pour la formule de leur dire qu'on a
appelés petits candidats ceux qui sont
contre ce thème
non ce que vous mettez les médias je
peux par les médias pendant et je suis
non mais je dis que quand vous avez les
fameux grands camps grands candidats
vous en avez deux qu'on présente comme
des sceptiques
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon est
une observatrice avisée vous aurez bien
vu que dans les derniers temps ces
deux-là nous disait que on allait voir
ce qu'on allait négocier
mélenchon dit moi je veux voir merkel
comptait 20 voix va se calmer on va
refaire à traiter la salle est autre
chose et vous allez voir dans le genre
on garde ne regarde pas tout en gardant
sous entendu on touche pas à l'euro
touche pas l'europe c'est bon ils
pouvaient faire partie des grands marine
le pen qui décide de tout des boutons
ligne être dur à ceux ci ce sera cela
fait état sur la question de l'europe
c'est la même chose on négociera après
la négociation on fera un référendum
on verra ce que donnera ce référendum
cet arbre ces deux là avaient gagné le
droit de faire partie des grands pas ce
qu'ils avaient montré des gages aux gens
qui estiment que la politique la vraie
la seule la sérieuse c'est de rendre
possible si je suis votre raisonnement
un candidat qualifié entre guillemets de
petits mais qu'on aurait dû qualifiés
selon vous de grands parce qu'il incarne
une véritable rupture par rapport à
l'euro et l'europe serait françois
asselineau
non je dis pas ça je dis que ce qu'il
dit lui alors c'est plus utile les
médias vous savez bien c'est à dire que
ils n'ont pas des gros sabots c'est
quand même beaucoup plus subtil que ça
donc on fabrique la petitesse du petit
candidat
on évite une grande visibilité si vous
évitez la visibilité sont pas bankable
nos petits candidats il reste petit
éventuellement ceux de beaux qu'on se
débrouille pour que des petits candidats
obtiennent 500 signatures c'est sidérant
ça et des gens que marine le pen un
temps ne parvenait pas où jean luc
mélenchon ne disait j'ai du mal avec
leur surface politique qu'ils avaient du
mal à trouver 500 signatures c'est drôle
asselineau qui fait zéro et quelques
enfin quasiment dessous de zéro il a ses
500 signatures il n'y a aucun problème
chemine al il a aussi ses 500 signatures
drôle quand même que ces gens là leur
signature
parce qu'effectivement revivifiant sinon
c'est ironique veuillez bien on choisit
des comics ou choisi des guignols jean
lassalle c'est formidable quand on a un
candidat comme ça il n'y a pas de
problème il est drôle c'est fantastique
c'est la ruralité il ya un accent
la vierge lui apparaît régulièrement ses
formes est sympathique et moi j'aime
beaucoup et poutou qui fait de ce cinéma
vous avez art autres de tout ça est bien
est ce que votre sympathique n'est pas
un peu condescendant c'est ce que vous
nous reprochez quant au volet de
sympathiques on a l'impression qu'ils
sont là pour amuser la galerie du bien
sûr que l'on qu'on les a choisis pour ça
mais bien sûr que les petits envie oui
on les choisit pour qu'effectivement on
leur facilite les choses
on s'arrange moi je voulais rencontrer
monsieur la salle j'aime beaucoup une
mer agitée on s'est rencontrés aux
déjeuners l'assemblée nationale et
m'expliquer qui le finance et comment
est assez intéressant de voir que on se
dit à bout de financer par ce monsieur
qui normalement n'a aucun intérêt
financier proposé de financer par lui et
on se voit effectivement on voit
effectivement que des gens ont intérêt
de dire pour la diversité
on a des individus qui sont là et qui
vont montrer qu'elle peut a bien vu que
la démocratie et tout le monde peut être
candidat puisqu'on a même cela nous et
qui veut aller sur la lune là un autre
qui chante eux en basque y en a un autre
alors c'est quand même grand la
démocratie mais pendant ce temps là cela
ils permettent finalement d'amuser la
galerie pendant que les sérieux vous
avez vu le premier débat télévisé on a
dit bon les comics on les laisse pas
voir son bord 11 personnes à prendre des
sérieux et avec les sérieux on avait
déjà commencé à un tri sélectif mais
dans ce théâtre là parlons d entre
guillemets seriez vous le dit avec
ironie
vous avez vraiment l'impression que sur
l'europe rien ne changerait que quand on
donne l'impression parce que là on prend
quand même deux candidats que tout
oppose deux visions du monde de vision
de la france avec un mac en dida qui va
être élu un candidat qui ne va pas être
élu c'est fait pour
c'est une élection à un tour l'élection
présidentielle et le président étaient
nuls
il y ait de rire la preuve il a déjà
fait la fête on est là parce qu'il a
fait la fête que les français elle passe
voilà je vois mal comment un candidat
qui qui à tout le monde pour lui
macron il à l'union rationaliste des
athées en même temps le pape il a le
medef quand même temps il ya la cgt il a
la droit depuis la gauche ila juppé mais
il a aussi
on voudra enfin il a tout le monde met
donc ça veut dire qu'il est habile ou
qui les fabriquait non il fabrique bien
sûr qu'ils fabriquaient jeu jean pierre
chevènement est un ami m'avait dit il ya
quelques temps tu peux le dire ce qu'il
a redit dans la presse donc et que
benoît hamon avait été choisi pour
perdre d'intéressant cette idée choisi
pour perdre les gens ont oublié que les
yeux là bourrages d'urnes au parti
socialiste n'a posé aucun problème
c'est plus important les vestons de deux
filles ont leur ouïe ouïe allons-y pour
les vestons de fillon mais un bourrage
d'urnes pourquoi fait-on un bourrage
d'urnes au parti socialiste quand même
étonnant ça non non il ya eu bourrage
d'urnes ont expliqué en 24 heures qu'on
aille mal compter qu'il a fallu
recompter tout tard mon oeil quand on
bourre les urnes c'est parce qu'on veut
pousser un candidat pourquoi est-ce
qu'on pousse un candidat en évitant en
faisant de telle sorte que il puisse
descendre tellement bas que ça ouvre la
route à macron dont on découvre
aujourd'hui nous écoutent un possesseur
et se disent oh la la
michel onfray il est un peu complotisme
je le joue donne des faits je vous donne
des faits je vous dis aujourd'hui
françois hollande nous a dit qu'il
fallait voter macron il l'a dit il ya
trois mois déjà ou deux mois parce que
pour les gens qui suivent un peu l'être
m'attendais de votre chaise non non non
pas du tout il est allé au liban
notre ami macron quand vous allez au
liban et que vous être aussi par
l'ambassadeur ça veut dire que le quai
d'orsay donné son autorisation donc le
chef de l'état donne son accord et a lui
aussi reçu par le président a parlé même
c'est pas exactement la même chose me
dit voilà oui le président du liban
il est souverain et autonome il reçoit 6
lire en revanche quand vous êtes reçus
par l'ambassadeur du liban vous êtes
reçus par la france elle quand elle est
là des systèmes quand il ya de la
république candidat du président oui oui
ça c'était le candidat du président donc
tout a été fait pour qu'il soit élu et
il va être élu et au delà peut-être des
candidats et c'est ce que vous pointez
souvent michel onfray c'est peut-être ce
qui est plus inquiétant au delà du nom
d'untel ou d'unetelle c'est que selon
vous d'un renoncer notre souveraineté
c'est-à-dire que vous dites directement
comprend word à bruxelles c'est à dire
quoi que demain le 8 mai on va passer un
coup de fil a acquis à madame merkel à
ces pannes ou que l'on passé des coups
de fil et on va nous passer des coups de
fil comme on sonne un domestique dans
monsieur le président vous avez vu
aujourd'hui c'est extraordinaire la
bourse c'est formidable tous les marchés
sont rassurés moi je lui la presse ce
matin
en allemagne on souffle aux états unis
on voit que les marchés sont très
heureux et très concret trop content
très content on a bien voté
les marchés sont sont tranquilles sont
heureux sont contents d'avoir tout est
fait pour ça donc oui effectivement le
chef de l'état qui nous donne
l'impression qu'il va choisir ne
choisira rien parce que le jour où il
sera élu on lui fera savoir ce qu'il
faut faire parce qu'une feuille de route
et la feuille de route et l'état brut
qu'est ce que vous proposez est ce qu'il
faut faire exploser quoi les règles du
jeu c'est un étape te propose tout ça
moi je propose street chien c'est ça
l'instruction il faut le casser
et qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire une
révolution parce qu emmanuel macron vous
avez lu son livre ont vu le titre oui ça
c'est pour rire révolution chez makro
laissez moi rire non c'est quoi une
vraie révolution alors elle va se faire
dans la rue avec peuvent alors soit on
est dans la logique de jean luc
mélenchon c'est la révolution jacobine
un couple et est si robespierre moi
c'est bon c'est mon ennemi robespierre
je pense que on ne doit pas pouvoir
faire couler couler le sang et les
guillotines de son talent sont à refuser
moi mon modèle c'est plutôt la commune
de paris la commune de paris met le feu
à la guillotine dans ce que je propose
ici c'est effectivement une révolution
si on veut mais je veux pas galvauder le
mot je dis juste qu'on doit à 100% faire
couler le sang évidemment sans couper
des têtes même symboliquement même
réellement dire réorganisant les choses
autrement
c'est à dire que on a le vieux schéma la
cité de dieu la cité des hommes chez
saint-augustin on nous dit dans le ciel
il ya un dieu donc sur terre il faut
qu'ils sont équivalents et c'est la
monarchie pendant des siècles la
révolution française dit on arrête avec
la monarchie
il ya deux courants dans la révolution
française un premier qui est jacobins
qui nous dit on arrête sans arrêter tout
en arrêtant c'est à dire que robespierre
restaure le culte de l'être suprême le
temple de la raison en disant il faut de
la mystique pour faire de la politique
la musique c'est moi en gros ce mal chef
j'ai avec moi le clergé et puis donc ça
veut dire que on a une descente comme ça
on s'assure du ca descendu au comme ça
et c'est ce qu'on appelle la hiérarchie
étymologiquement le pouvoir du sacré et
ça descend jusqu'aux sujet jusqu'à
maintenant et les manants et obéissent
il faut faire savent pas faire ça sur le
marché n'avait pas le droit d'exposer un
lapin parce que les directives de
bruxelles nous explique que si vous
n'avez pas une chambre froide qui a été
acheté à tel endroit avec les normes
ceci est à vous pouvez pas donc voilà
c'est le thème que vous les cartes et à
l'envers on part de la base
et cette révolution que je propose si
vous voulez vraiment qu'on utilise le
mot
c'est la pensée provinciale c'est oui si
vous voulez si on peut la résumer 12e au
mot et vous c'est formidable et provence
n'est pas dit le contraire nous rend
très haut débit je dis juste que quand
on est quand on veut on veut faire de la
politique à partir de la base
on dit il y a des intelligences
collectives il y a des gens qui savent
des paysans des agriculteurs des
instituteurs des médecins des gens de
terrain des gens qui sont là qui savent
comment ça marche
une vigne comment ça marche un village
comment ça fonctionne et c'est un
acheteur de nombreux donnons le pouvoir
aux communes avec des gens qui sont
susceptibles de faire de telle sorte que
le citoyen face de pouvoir c'est le
principe de l'autogestion et puis après
ça grimpe c'est à dire ça descend pas du
ciel ça grimpe jusqu'à 1 et ares va pas
rentrer dans le détail mais on peut
constituer un état qui soit une
libertaire parce qu'il serait la
garantie des libertés
plutôt que l'état théocratique qui
dessinent qu' il est autoritaire et le
cher décidera pour tout le monde nous
attendons des solutions d'un homme
providentiel c'est beaucoup c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs il nous séduisent
avec moi il y aura ceux du rap l'une des
jours vous verrez la fameuse d'essence
ordinaire
oui mais j'aime les gens qui sont qui
sont au contact mérité je reçois
nombreux invités vous le dites vous avec
talent cette forme de d'état fait
d'avoir nouveau vous voulez mais
d'autres l'ont dit et n'y arrive pas
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas juste
les autres à d'autres d'autres
personnalités quand même venu de la
société civile qu'on voulu incarner cela
cet état là qui serait moins central et
il n'ya si vous voulez que je cite des
noms et alexandre jardin il y en a
d'autres
en quoi est-ce qu'on n'y a pas écoutés
en dieu mais pourquoi votre votre
j'avais dit la respiration marcherait
plus que celle des autres sur la même
idée je dis pas ça je dis qu alexandre
jardin il a vu une excellente idée il a
dit à un moment donné il va falloir que
une espèce de consultation citoyenne
permettent de faire monter de faire
émerger un an que je trouve ça
extrêmement la méthode en frais et
comment ça s'est passé avec jardin un
jour il a dit au fait le nom qui émerge
sémien et c'est moi qui serai le
candidat de cette société et d'un seul
coup de gentilles ils ont découvert à la
radio à la télévision qu alexandre
jardin s'était autoproclamé candidat de
la société civile
il n'y a pas obtenu les signatures
c'était pitoyable cette idée était bonne
d'ailleurs quelques unes de ses idées
sont pas garants l'idée pour vous dit
tout quelques-unes de ses idées sont
bonnes parce que c'est s'il est bien une
ce sont les miennes et qu' il connaît
mon travail
il s'en sert assez régulièrement non
mais j'ai dit je sais très bien où il
est venu à l'université populaire il
connaît mon travail
et puis vous savez constate une chose
quand on s'inspire des idées des autres
c'est qu'elle s'embarque et mieux c'est
de les citer parce que là au moins on
est capable de dire qu'on peut
travailler en synergie que par exemple
l'université populaire c'est très
exactement une proposition concrète et
qui rentraient tout à fait dans les
projets ou les programmes d'alexandre
jardin mais ce n'est pas important et
son jardin
je pense que ce qui était important
c'était cette idée qui a été dévoyé
hélas cette bonne idée à l'origine
d'alexandre jardin il a été dévoyé par
quelqu'un dont on a découvert qu'il
était dans une logique jacobine et on a
besoin d'un chef et le chef ce sera moi
il est un cette logique là et si vous
devez vous laisser je sais que c'est
très difficile que vous n'aimez pas ça
parce qu'on pourrait dire une gauche
anti libérale est profondément
libertaire voulait des étiquettes
allons-y de même nous absolument gauche
antilibérale c'est ma cohérence depuis
le début donc certains pointent en
disant oui mais une fois il ya eu celui
ci plus de foyers une celui-là est
erratique
oui on peut effectivement imaginer qu'il
ya des contradictions dans cette dans
cette aventure
mais je vous rappelle que ce qu'il y ait
ces individus là c'est effectivement une
gauche antilibérale et précisément une
gauche libertaire et jeudi qui est le
personnage qui m'inspire c'est proudhon
oui c'est un socialisme libertaire
justement qui qui démarre dès des
communes des communautés de l'auto de
l'autogestion du talon des gens mais
quand vous dénoncer critiquer l'europe
savait ce qu'on va vous dire on va vous
accuser de tous les maux x tout ça j'ai
un peu l'habitude de problème c'est
parce qu'on dit deux mots ce qu'on pense
de bras ce que des gens puissent
entendre un discours alternatif et que
les gens puissent se faire directement
un âge c'était pour arriver à ça que je
voulais je vous disais ça on ne veut pas
entendre un discours alternatif sur
l'europe aujourd'hui parce qu'on avait
quand même l'impression nous pas dans ce
débat qui est pas mal de candidats
souverainistes qui voulait la sortie de
l'euro qui voulaient faire la peau à
l'europe
oui mais lesquelles des gens qu'on a la
cité de nouveaux françois sinon on va
pas que je soutiens voilà mais pourtant
ses idées
ne sont pas audibles c'est la question
de l'effet jamais consulté deux textes
et articles web et pas torse a
simplement fait le sale générer des
quolibets le lendemain on s'est moqué de
lui en disant il y avait des commis
alors que lui montrer qu'il fallait
tenir une deuxième chance de ces règles
du jeu pour les comptes en absolument il
disait mais en fonction de cet article
vous ne pourrez pas faire c'est que vous
énoncez on peut pas entendre ce propos
la qui est un propos justes et un propos
vrai dit mais simplement si vous restez
dans cette règle du jeu vous ne pourrez
pas et on s'est dit ça n'est pas entendu
ce n'est pas compris et on dilue tout ça
parce qu'on dit bon c'est aussi un
personnage qui fait partie de ceux qui
estiment qu'on doit pouvoir aller sur la
lune et donc on est évidemment si nous
l'idée de quelqu'un qui pense qu'il faut
se dépêcher pour partir sur la lune bah
voila quoi c'est une cédule idée de
quelqu'un de l'unr pour rester le
divorce paris province et une rupture
permanente comment la soigner
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il faut mettre
plus de justice tout simplement de bon
sens
les girondins d'idées très précisément
il avait 83 départements l'époque 1 les
girondins disait paris doit peser 1 83e
de la représentation nationale
bah voilà ça me paraît normal que paris
ne pèse pas 95% pendant non je dis 95
une majorité on dira et que tout se
passe là moi j'habite en normandie si on
doit prendre un train si on le connaît
si on doit prendre un avion si on doit
et c'est en fait tout passe par paris
si on veut voir son éditeur si on veut
dire s'exprimer sur les sur les chaînes
nationales mais effectivement il n'ya
pas de décentralisation il faut passer
par paris tout est à paris et
effectivement c'est une vraie révolution
d'imaginer que on pourrait redonner aux
provinces des pouvoirs et notamment de
drones de redonner du pouvoir serait
donc c'est la salle en vo la vraie
révolution je reviens à l'autre
révolution vous avez critiqué tout à
l'heure encore une question en tête
malgré tout michel onfray n'était pas
connu quelques mois quelques années en
tous les cas
emmanuel macron sans parti sans soutien
on a eu beaucoup après
vous les connaissez on peut on peut les
citer est ce que ce n'est pas quand même
un changement en douceur
même si le mot révolution est galvaudé
malgré donc découvrir un service la
bible de ces gens là c'est orwell c'est
à dire que vous avez des cabinets de
consultations qui ont fabriqué un
programme qui n'est pas un programme
voilà un homme qui nous dit il n'y a pas
besoin d'avoir un programme et france
elle aurait avalé tout cru
évidemment puisque c'est tous les jours
c'est tous les jours qu'on vous fait
savoir que finalement il ya les mauvais
d'un côté il ya les bons de l'autre que
les mauvais sont parfois ridicules
parfois c'est à les comics s'en donnent
à coeur joie et puis à moment donné vous
finissez par dire
finalement il reste plus que 6 de celui
là regardez quoi ça ressemble
aujourd'hui toute la palinodie de gens
qui disent ah non on va pas voter pour
macron va voter contre marine le pen non
en gros ils sont bien obligés de voter
pour celui qui a été choisi par par
céquami des cabinets de consultation on
se dit voilà il ya des segments dafa
loire drague et cela alors là un jour on
dit il n'ya pas de culture n'y a pas de
culture française deux fois en vingt
d'algérie et on va parler du génocide
notre foi on va à flatter la croupe du
cheval de deux jeunes d'attraction des
responsables politiques c'est pas
nouveau non musulmanes à chaque fois
vous avez emmagasiné un secteur un
segment de la société
et quand vous avez dit du bien de jeanne
d'arc quand vous avez dit du bien du
général de gaulle quand vous avez dit du
bien de françois mitterrand quand vous
avez dit du bien
d2d du fln par exemple en algérie quand
vous avez dit il n'y avait pas de
culture française et que vous avez
séduit tous les incultes ça fait du
monde
eh bien il ya un moment donné où chacun
en tant que ce qui lui a été dit
personnellement unis mais ça ça me va et
ce personnage
on va laisser de côté le reste
finalement je vais voter pour lui voilà
pourquoi on a des gens comme robert hue
qui soutiennent cet individu qui est
aussi soutenue oui oui non mais on cite
souvent le l'arc de robert donc c'est
quand même c'est quand même
un coup de force et de réussir un
programme de comme c'est ce qui fait
qu'un jour comme comme par hasard vous
allez acheter cet instrument ce
téléphone cette voiture je ne sais quoi
un jour tout est fait dans la logique
publicitaire pour que le jour où vous
ayez besoin d'une lessive vous achetiez
la lessive macron en tous les cas votre
révolution à vous elle s'appelle la
province les provinces on la retrouve
dans ce livre des colonisés et province
michel onfray merci d'avoir été notre
invité moi qui vous remercie retourne
dans ma province
on arrive à la fin cette émission mais
d'abord ce soit le moment choisi certes
public sénat nous avons beaucoup de gens
qui tapent à notre portefeuille mois
nous ont beaucoup de mal
énormément de contacts beaucoup de gens
en effet qui ont voté fillon qui sont
des patriotes beaucoup de gens qui ont
voté jol vous mélenchon beaucoup de gens
qui ont voté du conte aignan il y a par
rapport à l'élection 2012 est une vraie
différence aujourd'hui une opportunité
pour marine le pen ce qui a un réservoir
aujourd'hui est que le clivage droite
gauche est totalement révolu et
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas sur un
problème d'homme on va pas s'en plaindre
de partie on est sans problème
aujourd'hui de territoire et de logique
vous est patriote ou ne pas patriote
vous êtes européiste vous êtes vous êtes
europa est simple mais bien et non
le mouvement en marche il ne doit pas
arrêter de dkny de marché et s'ils
n'arrêtent pas de marché il doit
effectivement devenir un parti politique
je vous donne un exemple on arrête
l'analogie parce que emmanuel c'est un
homme de son âge qui heureusement n'a
pas connu alliance allant du général
toujours générale en france quand il
fait effectivement sa première majorité
il crée son parti lui nerfs mais il ya
aussi la cph you qui est adoubé ya une
volée les démocrates chrétiens il ya les
indépendants à l'intérieur de la vème
république vous avez toujours eu des
majorités de coalition mais attention
attention et le président toujours son
parti lui nerfs pour ou le rpr pour les
gaullistes l'udf pour valéry giscard
d'estaing le ps % mitterrand mais ils
n'ont jamais gouverner seuls avec leur
parti il ya toujours une coalition de
partis mais il doit y avoir un parti qui
soutiennent le projet du président et
c'est l'objectif dans marche qui doit se
transformer en parti qui peut être grand
parti démocrate
je pense que toutes les images de donald
trump entre un personnage et gothique
c'est à dire qu'il parle avant tout de
lui parle de lui et donc il dit bah oui
j'ai été ému bon j'espère qu'à chaque
fois qu'il est ému par quelqu'un qui
meurt dans le monde il va pas envoyer
des bombes et il qui va pas se laisser
aller à ça pulse youn alité permanente
dire que ils peuvent à ce contenu alors
ensuite le fait qu'il peut pas se
contenir il peut on l'utilisé pour sa
communication
mais la première des choses c'est que
cette flexibilité qu'ils revendiquent
c'est quelque chose qui doutent ils
peuvent pas faire l'économie
d'accord donc vous vous dites ya quand
même quelque chose qui est lui qui
dépasse la communication complète bon
ensuite ils utilisent
et on arrive à la fin de cette émission
merci encore de votre fidélité votre
rendez vous matinal demain ces
territoires d'infos content moi je
retrouve avec plaisir à 22h merci encore
belle fin de soirée en notre compagnie
[Musique]
à